this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by manscaped
talkspacehellofreshandstamps.com
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here
doing it in the night pants studio i am
ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media i can't thank you all
enough for real like
moving into this space we're a couple
months in now and
um i i appreciate every single one of
you for your support
it means the world so um if you're new
here or even if you just haven't yet
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
channel
you get the audio on mondays you get the
video on tuesdays all right make sure
you're subscribed to the patreon as well
the honeydew with you all that's where
i'm highlighting the low lights
with y'all okay so if you think you have
a story
that needs to be heard or you know
someone just got that [ __ ] story
email me at honeydewpodcast gmail.com
and uh look we got a lot of emails but
we're getting through them
and we'll get you on and do an episode
with you all also make sure you
subscribe to the facebook fan page all
the social media stuff
the website is the honeydewpodcast.com
that is where you get the merch and
night pants nation i can't thank you all
enough
for uh cutting the legs off and making
them night shorts you guys are buying
this [ __ ] out of the night it is hot
this year it's like extra hot so
stay comfy stay cool uh get your hoodies
for the fall
whatever you want it's all over there
and as you know i say all the time where
i record i record here at the santa
monica music center
we just officially got windows y'all we
just officially got some windows in but
a few months but we uh we got the glass
so very excited to have that in and
thank you all for your support there
if you guys are looking for lessons for
yourself your kids whatever
you want to be uh trained by a kick-ass
los angeles musician
go to santa monicamusic.com use the code
honeydew they'll wave the registration
fee they'll give you a free lesson when
you sign up
for a package all right that's all the
biz right there
now as you know we do here every week we
highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers i am very excited
to have our guest here today first time
here on the honeydew
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
brett ernst you all right
what's up kid
it's so weird like how we got to be not
formal but it's like we've known each
other so much
i don't know then you got to throw the
cash
[Laughter]
you're watching i got to say man this is
phenomenal bro thank you very proud of
you man
i appreciate it really i really am this
is uh how'd you come up with honeydew
you probably explained that already
yeah a bunch but at long story short you
need me to google later
no long story short i'm sitting at the
diner having
dinner one night they bring the fruit
cup i eat everything in it but the
honeydew
and not cause i don't i hate honeydew i
just don't [ __ ] with the honeydew and as
i walk out i see honeydew scattered on
on all these tables and i was like huh
it's a perfectly good fruit that a lot
of people just throw away
and then it hit me that i am a [ __ ]
i'm a honey dude i'm a human honeydew
and so are you yeah so are all these
people that come on here and share this
i feel that way about old bay seasoning
i can't stand old bay i think that's the
worst [ __ ] hey guys that's my time
i know you guys [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
in baltimore bro it's a it's a flagship
sponsor here
is it really i was gonna say i wish i'm
dude
every time i'm in baltimore man i put it
on everything i know you do tuna
eggs everything all seafood all fish
chicken all of it i just always old bay
and [ __ ] always
that's our hot sauce you know what i
mean yeah that's why they made a hot
sauce i just bought a 64 ounce gallon of
hot sauce look anyway um it is great to
have you here
we're going to talk about some [ __ ]
today but before we do please
promote everything you want to promote
uh well first
august 28th cobra kai is going to go to
netflix so we were on
youtube premium for like uh the first
two seasons so
oh it was exclusive to the youtube
premiere it was like their first
flagship show
and then uh so i'm going around just you
know
trying to push that the uh it's going to
netflix both seasons
yeah and then they're gonna release
season three once everybody's uh caught
up because
we already shot season three on netflix
on net okay well no it was still with
youtube premium but they just bought all
three they're gonna stream it now got it
and then hopefully you know season four
comes back that's great and then also
uh yeah uh check out my uh my special
we're at i'm at to like
2.6 million views now um
but i put it on youtube man and uh
you're one of the earliest guys to do
that
yeah dude you uh here's what i love they
say no to everybody we
talk about this you schultz joe list is
mark norm and all you guys are putting
it uh um
hold on sam morrow all these guys
putting it out there right now
uh go check all these specials out the
one of the funniest
just let me say it the funniest goddamn
bits
you will ever see is the roller skating
bit i know you're probably sick of it
whatever it is
the funniest [ __ ] bit and i take my
daughter roller skating now and there's
no
way now well not right now but prior to
this
we go we go to the old school rink we go
to moonlight roll away
i still got it i'm still out there doing
the shuffling i'm stepping over and [ __ ]
i never could backward skate but i'm
stepping over and [ __ ] i'm still
throwing it up to the weird dj you know
give them some love
uh but i can't not think about that guy
because all i would always would always
be a bigger guy would pick you up and
[ __ ] and move you and even
you know what i mean remember that guy
and even as a 10 year old i felt like as
a man i'm like [ __ ] don't move
but i couldn't do [ __ ] about it he's
like
your hands around my waist and move me
i'm ten man
you're just a dude no uh
we um no but here's the thing man is
what i was saying is that now you know
what here's my
i think the silver lining and you know
look there's that dirty little
secret in hollywood with the white guys
you know there's no more white males
we're not doing that you know which by
the way i wasn't white
enough when white dudes were in and i'm
not brown enough when
white guys aren't in uh personally my
problem was i was never good with social
media
you know what i mean that was just my
thing but um
what's beautiful now is that all the
comedy is back where it belongs and
that's underground
i always thought and also i always in
the hands of the
comedians it's not but
absolutely that's where it should be one
and two like comedy's punk rock dude
it's
you know it's it is it is it's it's
underground man it's underground hip-hop
it's
it's things that that we're supposed to
be saying or or you know you're not
afraid to say
you know depending on which it doesn't
matter you know
we're contrarians by nature but anyways
let me say this for a minute for for all
the time on our end we feel like
that that industry or the whatever keeps
us from the fans that we know
would love this [ __ ] if they got it say
what you said earlier about the
the the group that you see yes so so
there was there's always been and then
we're gonna get into your low lights but
there's always been this
this wall you know this huge wall
of of managers agents bookers
whatever saying well i'm not saying
you're not funny but we're gonna let
this one over and this one and this one
and this one and this one and this one
but
you just stay right there well what
these people
men and women that that were put here
did
was build [ __ ] armies
and went right through that goddamn wall
was like [ __ ] you
and then prove not only to to to
everyone else but themselves that
they were right all along these
gatekeepers are they've never set foot
on a
why am i listening to anything you have
to [ __ ] say until you get up on that
stage for an
hour and [ __ ] rock a mic for 2 500
[ __ ] people don't even tell me
better yeah stand in line for 15 years
that's right you know uh but hold on let
me say this because this is important
because i just
i recently thought of this too like we
always see it as man
i want to get to the fans i want to get
to the fans and
these people i have the best [ __ ]
fans i have the greatest [ __ ] fans
and you don't ever look at it like
their side like well this is all you're
gonna give us
you know what i mean like this is it i
know there's gotta be a million other
things but this is all we get
you know so i've never looked at it like
that side of
they're happy that we did what we did
and got
figured a way around but you know listen
man don't listen to anybody
hear me don't listen to anybody do what
the [ __ ] you want to do i always say you
don't need permission to exist
nope but um yeah it just seemed that
like we look i came out here just to
entertain
you know you know and then they start
asking you about your politics and
what the [ __ ] that matter you know and
then it's almost like they're checking
the wrong
boxes you know the boxes that should be
checked are they talented are they funny
you know do the fans love it yeah yeah
i'm saying are they good are they are
they charismatic i mean you know what
what actors used to be now it's just
you know it's what gender what what you
know blah
and they just check in the the wrong
boxes sometimes and it just doesn't make
any sense and by the way i'm okay
with the equality thing but at the same
time then get the good
equality in yes you know what i mean
like there's there's some
uh comics out there that like like you
know like corey holcomb do
like that guys what can i believe he is
you know i mean i'm not saying he hasn't
created his own niche too yeah
but i mean there's comics that comics
know that like when that dude's on stage
you're like yo
this [ __ ] is just a beast man
you know and
but thank god for the internet i mean
because let's just say we didn't have
one
would would we i mean i know joe diaz
was was was uh in move but would we have
had uncle joey the way we have uncle joe
what all of us will be all out there
have anything this show they would have
they would have [ __ ] canceled us
uh eight years ago yes they said you
know what we're going another way
but look it is a business and we know
that so you know i'm not mad at it
i'm just saying i think this is a good
thing and that
that that's my original statement is
that now comedy is where it needs to be
it's a consumer-based thing and and you
know
the good is good and it's punk rock and
it's not pop comedy anymore and
you know you can go you can go get some
real [ __ ] now
yeah you can you can enjoy whatever porn
and comedy is the best it's ever been
porn is killing it porn is accessibility
is better
you don't have you don't need a video
tape that we have to hand around and
rewind and
at this point now if you have an idea
then you got to figure out how to do it
yourself
because if i had to pitch this show to
any network like i told you data said no
if tom segura would have pitched your
mom's house to a network data told him
get the [ __ ] no right but look where
they are
so anyway yeah there's no excuses let's
talk about you now
we go back a long ways you you
originally are florida
no jersey originally okay jersey
originally but florida was your
okay so give me a brief background
on family and let's talk about because i
really want to talk about your brother
i love that you include him in your
stand up i love that you don't shy away
from any of that stuff because
just go ahead start start with your i
was born in new jersey
and then well i went to 15 different
schools 15
yeah i was always moving were you was it
why
um you know single mom [ __ ] okay
it wasn't military right now i don't
know
nothing productive i mean look man you
know there's periods in my life
like six is when everything goes south
but you know
we were always moving and then um and
sometimes like they'd switch zones on
you and you had to get bust in
and you know that type of [ __ ] and then
my but my my
i spent my four years in plantation high
school in fort lauderdale
so that was uh where i spent my i had i
was fortunate to go to one high school
my older brother went to three and that
sucked
but i went to three middle schools
and then the rest elementary but
something like what was different in
florida
elementary was sixth seventh eighth but
then we moved back to jersey then i was
back
uh i mean middle school was sixth
seventh and eighth then we moved back to
jersey and then i went back to
elementary because
middle school was seventh and eighth so
it was always moving and stuff
you know but uh i mean
how many brothers do you have two i have
two why i also have a step older brother
okay and a step older sister so i've
never heard anybody drop the older after
the step
it's usually an older step brother or an
older state you said step older brother
and step older
sister i'm also stupid
[Music]
i'm not that bright no claim to be your
mom raised
three kids on her own yeah then i had a
stepfather later on
all right so what age are uh you when
your dad splits or do you never meet
your dad
i knew my father uh i mean i remember
him
at six that's the worst because i'm the
middle like i don't know if it's worse
not knowing them right
or just how young how much younger is
your younger brother
keith was three when my parents split
and then my brother was
10 my older brother but my older brother
was more like my father figure
because my older brother you know he
took he took the burden of everything so
he he raised everybody you know like he
was always
my mom was always working so he was
always there you know
in what ways like was he like he looking
after you after school
yeah like i met there there was he would
like he taught me how to ride a bike
[ __ ] like that your older br
your ten-year-old wow yeah he put me on
and just pushed the [ __ ]
but he told me i had to swim the same
way too
so you guys got really close because
your mom's always working
yeah you latch key kids and bouncing
around just like everybody in our era
yeah that was a big thing in the 70s and
80s i don't think that exists now
maybe it does but not like it did latch
i think
social service is going to pick your ass
up well you know i have a theory man is
that like our parents were raised
where you know they always talked about
the lights came on you came home
and that's how we were raised but the
difference was
when they were outside in the 50s and
then being outside in the 80s
are two different outsides so they
raised us the same way they were raised
but our outsides were way different and
that's why we don't let our kids go out
that's what i was saying that's like
right now you have pairs that are like
hell nah man i don't wanna
my kid's gonna my kid's gonna come
across a crack addict that's jerking off
in front of him exactly no like our [ __ ]
was crazy
20 20 kids are not outside kids i was i
used to tell my ex-wife man because she
was younger than me
yeah they are not
like why aren't you outside riding your
bike oh yeah cause 12 people try to
kidnap you on the way to the
park yeah dude we had this dude man and
uh uh
matt matty fontana talked about this but
uh we're like there was a guy that used
to like jerk off in front of kids and
but
everybody would be like you know you get
in trouble be like why the [ __ ] do you
go over there
you know that's what he knows that's
what he does you know what i mean just
go over there
you know what i mean it's your fault but
i i mean also two minutes
until i used to tell my uh ex-wife this
because she was younger than me by like
almost 15 years i said when we were kids
i said when we were kids
no [ __ ] we could go to the corner
store and i could buy
cigarettes and wine for my mom and then
you just walk in they weren't even
behind the counter they were right out
here by the candy bars and [ __ ] that's
how we used to steal
all the time my buddy had the best
method i i say it all the time he would
walk up
he grabbed two walk around the store
slip one in his pocket like
i'm not gonna buy that put one back buy
a big golf bounce
every listen a thou he batted a thousand
on that
and then when they moved and behind the
register that was all she wrote but yeah
we could
my ninth grade year in high school we
had a smoking lounge
we had a [ __ ] smoking lounge if you
were under 18 you had to get your
parents permission to
smoke they used to bring guns man they
had like a sharpshooters club but
[ __ ]
like cool kids in high school were
bringing guns and [ __ ] and they were
like
shooting them no where you going
i got competition at 2 30. all right
they literally had those clubs man
but um no it was it was just a different
different thing so we were always
outside man
always into something man always and
what else i i like
about our generation too uh is that
video games came during then and we
weren't just sucked into them
we were at least we had a good balance
we were like let's go out the graphics
kind of sucked
yeah they did but still it was new it
was new when double dribble had their
hair
yeah oh i was like what the button i
remember
yeah but now they're making [ __ ]
money you know making careers out of
these but see now
there there's an interesting study on
this is it's it's
the the gap like okay if the
my grandparents music and my mom's music
were totally different
my mom's music and our music were
totally different we're still in the
[ __ ] hip-hop era
yeah like they're we're we're listening
to the same music dude
you know what i'm saying that our kids
aren't i still listen to run dmc
i still but we're also listening to
kendrick lamar yeah
and stuff the kids are listening and
we're also still there yeah
the video game generation like i i just
was getting my ass kicked by my niece
and uh
yeah i know she's still playing
marijuana yeah it's [ __ ] awful it's
annoying she's ten
and i i'm literally like i won like four
four i got
four races i won but um yeah no anyway
so uh
uh also what's interesting about our
generation is that we're the first
generation that's getting
older online you know what i mean like
these kids were we it started when we
were
in 96 right and then you can literally
look back at us and go
yeah like you ever get your facebook
memories like that's
nothing like me who is that guy i
literally had the thought the other day
i saw somebody updated their profile
picture and i was like he looks good man
he's getting older he looks good as he's
getting older and i'm thinking as he's
cause we're watching it unfold you know
we're the first people that didn't have
this [ __ ]
like you got to go back prior to what at
96 on 23
prior to like let's just say 2000 before
social media got big or whatever you got
to go look
at hard copy photos to see what i look
like
before that you can't just scroll your
thumb up and look back at my baby
pictures
you know what i mean now do you think
too like i don't know man are people
printing these photos though
are they just gonna live in cyberspace
cause we used to have albums yeah
you know which is what you had but i
don't know if i don't know if kids that
people do that now and then yeah they
just look on their phone or
drop it to you you know yeah i airdrop
what i'm saying
if it's not on your phone does anybody
ever see him again i mean it goes on
social media if they don't follow you
that's it but let's just say it all
[ __ ] goes away the last 25 years are
gone yeah
it's a fire it's a fire it's like our
fire yeah when you had a house fire
everything was [ __ ] gone
we lost all the albums everybody
you know what i mean like your [ __ ]
collapses that's it you got 25 years
you're just a grown man now they don't
see anything middle school none of that
[ __ ]
your trophies aren't proof nothing
nothing
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor manscaped
do you have a moose near the caboose
that needs to be tamed i'm talking hairy
big and needs some support
thankfully our sponsor today manscaped
has you covered to keep the hair looking
nice
and trimmed and feeling fully supported
manscaped offers precision engineered
tools
for your family jewels i don't know
about you guys but
i've been down there before trying to
work it you know what i mean like it's
basically it looked like i had a weed
whacker down there my
taint was all tattered it was bloody
beat up
you know come on you're trying to look
nice and then you're taking yourself out
of commission
don't be like me the manscaped
engineering team just perfected the
greatest ball hair trimmer ever created
the premium lawnmower 3.0 is waterproof
it includes an led light and it's made
with advanced skin
safe technology which reduces nicks and
cuts
on your delicates you can get this
trimmer inside their perfect package
3.0 which also includes the manscape
crop preserver ball deodorant
and the crop reviver ball tone and spray
both super practical and they smell
great too plus
for a limited time when you order the
perfect package kit you get
two free gifts just like balls two of
them the shed travel bag and the
manscaped anti-chafing boxer brief
the manscape boxer briefs have optimal
temperature control with their crop
cooling technology while keeping your
pride and joy supported
you gotta try this out for yourself all
right you can get 20 off and free
shipping right now with code honeydew
at manscape.com your balls
will thank you get 20 off and free
shipping with the code honeydew at
manscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
use the code honeydew from the moose to
the caboose
always use the right tools for the job
our next sponsor is talk space now if
you've been waiting for months to figure
out what your future's going to look
like you're not alone between the
uncertainty the waiting for answers and
the everyday
stressors of work school home school
and relationships and more it is a lot
to balance but if anything helps reduce
stress and anxiety it's talking things
out all right talkspace
has thousands of licensed therapists
trained in over 40 specialties
including anxiety depression
relationship issues and more if you have
something specific you want to work on
right now
they will find someone right for you
they're affordable
talk space is a fraction of the cost of
in-person therapy but with talk space
you can send unlimited messages to your
therapist and they'll engage with you at
least five days a week
and that just means you never have to
wait to share what's on your mind
they have a therapist network all talks
based therapists have experience
treating depression anxiety substance
abuse trauma relationship issues food
needing
and so much more they're very secure uh
and private they use the latest
encryption technology
to store client information now the
bottom line is that we all need someone
to talk to and talkspace wants to give
the license support we deserve at a
price we can afford as a listener
of this podcast you can get a hundred
dollars off your first month on
talkspace
to match with your perfect therapist go
to talkspace.com or download the app
make sure to use the code honeydew to
get 100 off your first month
and show your support for the show
that's honeydew
and talkspace.com now let's get back to
the do
all right let's talk more about your
brother raising you because
well he it was more like he we were very
close
you know it wasn't until like you know
puberty hits that people go the
different ways a little bit you know
because that's the other thing when
you're the
see i love being in the middle a lot of
people don't like that but i did because
i was both a younger brother and an
older brother
now me personally i like being an older
brother you know
um but you know there's that time when
like you're interested in girls and then
your little brother still wants to go
play you know football you're like yo
man
i'm wearing cologne i'm 12. i'm trying
to get laid here
now the difference is that
when my older brother was hitting
puberty he was liking dudes
so he was gay but you know that when did
you realize that
[ __ ] we always knew you did yeah i mean
i always knew i didn't know
you know you know what's funny too man
is that like
whenever you look at them and again i
have a tendency to
and i think everybody does this but i
have a tendency to to
say things based on like the way i was
raised and and the people i was around
like for instance yeah but but when i
hear like those
the white kids that they're always like
you know racism starts at home and you
know
my mother i didn't have the i'm sorry
you had a [ __ ] shitty family
my mother wasn't like that i wasn't
raised around that even with the gay
thing nobody [ __ ] cared that's what i
wanted to ask you because you're you're
definitely a
a dudes dude and there's a lot of
stereotypes that go into that so
had you known anybody else that was gay
or anyone else in the family you know
what's funny is like when when he came
out he was more afraid of me
to know but because i was always he
didn't think you'd accept it
no i was always saying [ __ ] as a kid
but when you're a young kid
[ __ ] doesn't mean [ __ ] it just means
yay stop being effects
it meant more like stop crying or
whatever being a [ __ ] but you know
you don't know that as a little boy i'm
saying it all the time and he's thinking
you know
he's feeling weird you say come on man
stop being gay but it doesn't mean gay
yeah you know what i'm saying so he was
always around that
and the way kids would talk and the way
i would talk but you know it's there's
no ill intentions
right it's just how you talk back then
but now i understand you know but
um did your mom have any conversations
with you guys about
that at all we just [ __ ] waited it
was more for him like you know he never
really so you guys were just waiting for
him to be comfortable enough to come out
yeah yeah yeah you know it's just like
all right
yeah we had and then how we had to act
shocked
[Music]
no really we had no idea
you had the whole family full you know
none of us figured that out bro the
whole family those pictures of marilyn
monroe on your wall
really [ __ ]
what do you remember how he did it how
old was he
he was like 18 or 19. okay so he did
wait he was finally waiting but you know
it just came to the point to where
if he didn't do what i was gonna say bro
come on man you know but was he dating
was he happy was he yeah
uh well see he he got aids pretty young
he did yeah so how old was he uh i think
he had to have been so let's see 23
yeah 23. but through just going back a
little bit before that through high
school did he ever
how did he date well here's the crazy
part like when we were kids
he he always hit on my girlfriends
you know what i mean but then there was
a kid this is hilarious too man
there was this kid that was on our block
that my brother that they used to
[ __ ] fool around
oh your brother and him yeah but this
guy was like you know he was like the
big dick
you know like you know like he was a
jerk like a bully and everything
but he was really the guy that uh that
you know um
then he my brother said yeah man i used
to [ __ ] when
you know as we got older you know he
would tell me stuff but a big bad bully
could suck your brother like that guy
it's like a good
[Applause]
[Laughter]
do you know how that would change the
game of bullying if you could have that
inside information
hey you remember so and so yeah man yo
you mean that guy used to beat the [ __ ]
out of his [ __ ] whistles
[Laughter]
remember the dude that stole your bike
yeah man hey i didn't beat him up
i just [ __ ] i made him pay though
no no you know there was like he would
always tell me [ __ ] too like later on
like you know so-and-so is gay this
celebrity's gay because
so we're fast forward a little bit so
you know he he he eventually you know we
we figured it out but then when he
started dating well just like anything
like he was with girls before so when he
told you guys do you remember where you
were
uh yeah it was did he do a family thing
or just talk to each of you
we were all i think we were in the
kitchen it just
and it was so nothing to you because you
all know yeah
but now now that's when the fun starts
but also you're
yes of course no but yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's
poor boss thing my stepfather was like
old school
right and he would have conversations
with him about
uh you know like he couldn't fat he
couldn't figure out
like if they he like he would say [ __ ]
like okay so you
say you because he had he had a couple
boyfriends that that you know they would
come over for family dinner i got a
great story yeah i want to hear about
the guys
it would be like he'd be like hey so if
you two go out like who pays
like he you know he couldn't fathom like
yeah he can't even get the dynamic he'd
be like so if he gets in a fight do you
run
run you know what i mean like that yeah
are you getting a car what are you doing
so he was dating this one guy uh that
was a doctor man
and uh he came over he would come over
every sunday and then
he came over one day and he wasn't there
so he's like yeah you know
we broke up whatever and and you see him
go oh me
the guy's a doctor what are you doing
right now he's all about he's out
we had a doctor here now he's all about
it but we would you know there was
i i gotta say something man and all of
you know the [ __ ] that that happens in
life i'm very very very very blessed to
have one of the
funniest and most loving families man
even my grandmother my everybody man my
grandfather didn't give a [ __ ]
my mom my mom wanted to be a nun man you
know
and it's just always we never had none
of that
you know everybody was [ __ ] really
cool man i'm not gonna lie
i had the same like my upbringing was
just
[ __ ] but god the family members were the
ones that good ones were awesome and and
funny as [ __ ] just naturally funny the
just the way they you know you remind me
a lot of my cousins and shits why
i laugh so hard listening to you you're
so you're so much like them
so all right so but my older brother was
very stoic so
like you know he took a breath in the
family now there was a time when me and
him did not get along
at all at all like he he was mad at me
and he and he told me later on
i said dude what the [ __ ] your problem
man yeah why why because i made fun of
him one time outside
in front of people yeah and then that's
when i explained him then you forget oh
yeah dude you're gay
it wasn't even about being gay it was
about being overweight because my
brother gained pounds when he was like
12.
i took his shirt off i called him like
dolly parton or something
meanwhile by the time he was 18 he was
[ __ ]
shredded my older brother was stunning
yeah every
every girl that came over like put you
like this man when you have a gay older
brother and i used to talk about this on
stage
it's like having a big sister whose
clothes you can wear right
because he knew how to dress but then
all his friends would be hot girls
and they always would ask do you have a
brother or you know
like i had a [ __ ] ton of first dates
because they'd be like they'd be like
yeah my bra and scott would be like yeah
i do
but you know we're not the same because
you know
my brother was very he wasn't rough
around the edges like me and my little
brother were
because me and my little brother were
always out there bro always hustling
always my older brother was more the
you know he took the role of like a
parent almost for us
so it was like he was like a father
figure to me and my little brother was
my best friend my partner in crime me
and my brother
little brother did everything but my
older brother we would
but it was i always just say he's a
fourth he was like a fourth quarter guy
all the little [ __ ] he'd lose his mind
but when [ __ ] hit the fan
dude that was the guy that was the guy
like when my father died and my brother
had to come get me and let me know
you know how they found him and
everything he uh
you know he was he didn't cry how was he
when he was telling me
geez no wait i'm sorry scotty was 14. i
was 10 still that's a 9th grader
but he was standing there and you know
and i would hear him cry at night
because we all we all shared the same
room
right it was me my little brother and
him in one room by you know most of my
life
so that's another reason why we're
always fighting yeah well i mean you
have you're on top of each other going
through
puberty going through all my little
brother never liked that we both loved
football we bought it was scott had
uh he there you know he just there was a
difference obviously man i mean which
again man you just
once you get a certain age you don't
care but you know there are those times
but then like he would
he took the but i would hear him crying
at night but he would never cry in front
of us
you know so what um what happened when
he got sick
my brother well he was pretty healthy
for a while man
and um it's it's like when he got uh
what was [ __ ] up is you ever see the
dallas buyers club
yeah yeah so i used to have to take him
we said there was a dude in miami we
used to get his [ __ ] from
and then that was helped for a while
yeah man because those aids cocktails
are like
they were like ten thousand dollars a
month at one point a month
yeah i know that that's crazy but here's
what else is [ __ ] up
is that at the time this is why i would
nev it's not that i have political
affiliations but it's why i'm
independent
like the republicans at that time they
cut they cut the money
so basically it was like uh uh
if you were healthy and you're doing
well then they said okay you're fine but
the only reason why you're healthy is
because of that [ __ ]
right so so you would take him to go
i would take him we'd have to go get
those [ __ ] cocktails man
but here's the [ __ ] up part i used to
blame the political
parties in the government but the
reality is if if there was if they
allocated a trillion dollars those
[ __ ] medical companies will find a
way to spend that whole trillion
of course so now all of a sudden it'll
double you know it was just it was an
endless amount of money that
eventually it runs out so i had a little
animosity towards that [ __ ] for a while
you know
but when did you find out he was sick oh
he told me
that was i'll tell you i could tell you
exactly what it was man
because i came in i [ __ ] knew man how
old are you
21 22. all right
right i don't know man i don't know it's
weird
it's like i i it's like it's weird i was
in that i was working in the nightclubs
at the time so i had to have been over
21 maybe 20
19 20 maybe i don't know
and where were you yeah scotty was 24.
so i'd have been 20. i was in florida
but i knew something was wrong man and
the dude the dude gave it to him on
purpose he gave it to like six guys on
purpose no
yeah and then and my brother's the only
one that went to his death bed and
forgave him
really yeah and if he didn't die before
my brother i would have [ __ ] he would
have died
that guy died too yeah for your brother
but what was [ __ ] up is my brother saw
the strain because
there's like different strains so the
way that guy went out scott knew that's
the way he was gonna go out
but if that guy wouldn't have died he'd
be dead yeah i would [ __ ] killed that
[ __ ] bro
i was angry at him for a while because
he pretty much murdered him man i mean
if you're killing six people
potentially like that i got over it you
know i mean now at the time i was angry
and
you look at it as an adult and my
brother forgave him and it's like
you know people go through things how
was your brother when he died
scotty was 33 age of jesus 33.
so he lived with it for a minute man and
he was pretty healthy but
when it hit it hit hard because my my
father was 30. my father was 38 when he
killed himself and my brother
was 33. all right so hold on wait i was
well go ahead
did this cocktail is what kept him
healthy
up until the end was that a big part of
it huge man but see
again i'm catholic man i believe in god
jesus you know
my brother did too and um and and
and there was a little kid that got hit
by a car right in front of scott
this was in miami so he ran over and
he's holding the little kid
and he just said to god he said listen
i'm gonna switch with him
but you know take me and not him and
then then he started getting sick
right that right after that yeah now my
brother did that kid live
yeah but here's the funny part i'm
waiting for you see like my brother had
the had the ultimate sense of humor man
you know like he had a dark sense of
humor then then he's like after he found
out the game was alive he's like god
you know okay hey
yeah [ __ ] maybe i shouldn't assign that
they're not my brother was a dude when i
tell you that [ __ ] was
funny man i'm glad he i'm glad he saw me
do comedy though
i wanted to ask you guys yeah he got to
see me do it man i was doing it uh
about three or four years because he
died no one
i had to come all the way home man what
was that like it's [ __ ] awful bro
but i went up on i went up did you get
to say goodbye oh [ __ ] yeah man i never
left his side okay
i lost everything all my money so you
came home bef
not you didn't get the call that he's
gone you came no okay no my mom
see this is the because we're all over
the place again he was
[ __ ] healthy and then it hit hard
then he went in i will say this man
um by the way if i get choked up you
edit that [ __ ] out
no we're not doing that no you got to i
don't know
no i laughed i'll tell you i'll tell you
what
what's [ __ ] up about it man so the
first time he was in
uh i'll tell you what [ __ ] with me
because you know you got to deal with
your mom so you say in so it was
the hospital but does he okay go there
so he's dying like we thought he was out
because this [ __ ] could my
brother was strong dude
look up uh this our our cousin like
my family my dad's family is extremely
strong
like i was i was strong when i played
ball i was a strong i've seen you i've
seen your old pictures though you're
looking at a goddamn chip and david was
was stronger than me now if you look up
google a guy named greg ernst he's the
world's strongest man like that this is
my father's side my grandfather was just
a
just a freakishly strong guy my brother
was
just a [ __ ] strong all the way around
strong
jawline just strong so he wasn't going
right so the first time we thought he
was gone
right and the nurses were there and then
my mom was freaking out so this [ __ ]
me up
i had to get his suit to get clean the
one we're gonna bury the [ __ ] in
so that that pisses you off yeah but
then he came back
right wait he made a comeback yeah he
didn't he didn't
he didn't die and then then he was
getting better now he had gotten sick
before
when then he he got better but the when
he came out he's like
i want to talk to you and i said what he
said look man if this if
i can't i can't if i go back in i can't
i can't beat it
and the [ __ ] went back in like a
week later then he actually said that to
you
yeah then i was like all right but like
i had to talk him over
he wouldn't go he was in the room he
wouldn't go man so i had to talk him
over
you know you talked him through it yeah
i told him to die i said bro you can
leave man i got my
worry about it you know so that part
kind of you know and you were there
on his last breath yeah well i went
downstairs
but yeah i i you know i got to tell you
something man and i know people don't
understand this when you're in these
situations
that's how you know there's a god and
and it's not that you
want to believe it [ __ ] starts to happen
so i was downstairs with my grandmother
and then um i knew right away i said we
gotta get upstairs
i swear walked in the room and my mom
was crying
and then i mean i don't want to get into
details with it but
there's a death rattle there's like a
final breath but but then there's a tear
he he cried he did yeah but you there's
a term for that
in italian you know the guineas are we
[ __ ] have all that uh
all that we you know superstitious [ __ ]
or whatever but
there's a word for that so there's any
italian people
anyways so then i spent time with them
you know alone we got we got to talk a
little but i kind of knew
so here's the crazy part man i was in la
jolla at the comedy store that night i
got on stage by the way that [ __ ]
night yeah that [ __ ] night didn't
even talk about it i
just went on stage man i just had to and
then
you know my little brother was home and
everybody was there the room was
comfortable man
it was [ __ ] comfortable we had music
playing for him gloria estefan came
came yeah because my brother was so gay
he was a backup dancer for her
yeah how do you leave that wait you want
to hear a great story hold on
yeah hold on hold on so [ __ ] do you
leave well she
she was doing what she's part of the
rhythm that god because my brother was
in miami
in south beach which was like the gay
heaven and uh
90s and early 2 like from mid 90s to
like early 2000s it was like
[ __ ] so when she came she came there to
visit him
and uh but here's a great story so i'ma
you know i'm a huge cowboy fan my little
brother i'm a diehard dallas cowboy fan
so
one of the the super bowl between the
the niners and the cincinnati bengals
my brother was a dancer at the uh super
bowl
yeah yeah so he had on like this [ __ ]
headdress and [ __ ] right
and and he's with his friends and he
goes
he goes oh my god there's tom landry
right and they're like who
so he goes over and he wants to go to
tom landry he's like hi
he's like can can you give me my
brothers would die if i could get an
autograph
from you
i got another one
you guys you and your brother are so
different than him
yet he's at the super bowl i don't wish
you could [ __ ] be but he's there
doing that dude that is [ __ ]
hilarious another time tom landry that
god they have had had to be look at this
dude another time this is even funny i
got i got two of these
so you know listen man my friends didn't
give a [ __ ] nobody gave a [ __ ] and if
they did give a [ __ ]
it would be like nobody was ever like
you see in the movies and my my friends
were [ __ ]
you know i had a rough rough crew of
guys i used to run with back in the day
remember this is during the beeper days
yeah yeah so i'm out with my crew
whatever
i get the page you remember you had your
own code
so it was a number and scotty had his
code
then it was a 9-1-1 i'm like oh [ __ ]
so i run to the pay phone right i used
to have a dialer
that yeah we used to sell like dialers
where like you would put
if you put it to the to the bottom of
the phone it would make a noise like a
coin droppings oh i didn't know yeah so
like the phone would read
it yeah yeah and it was so loud i
couldn't [ __ ] get it so now i gotta
run and get changed you know
remember when you would call somebody
collect or or
you would tell the operator that you
were disconnected when can you get your
change back remember
that that [ __ ] it's a long story for him
i said listen man
because i was in sunrise he was all way
down on broward boulevard
he said yo bro there's some uh there's
some dudes in a parking lot that are
waiting to [ __ ]
you know to beat people up you know
like they were gay bashing or whatever
because that was a thing
you know people beat the [ __ ] out of
them for fun they thought it was fun
unfortunately it's still a thing and my
brother goes uh i need you uh you know
he said look because my brother could
fight he wasn't a [ __ ] yeah he's like
man i can't he goes yo i ca
these dudes can't back me like his
friends
the rest of the [ __ ] sound machine
ain't gonna be helping my
hat
the rest of the sound machine that's
[ __ ] genius
[ __ ] hilarious the rest of the sound
machine isn't gonna
so i said to my boys i said yo man let's
go i said yo you know my brother's
hemmed up so we [ __ ] get in the car
we pull up
puna parking lot we get out like yo
what's up man you know
them dudes had left already they had
left so my brother's sitting there he's
like yeah now they left everything's
fine
but uh that's when he said he said yeah
you know and all his friends
were behind i'm like he goes you know
he's like
like who's that you know like when we
showed up but he's like yeah he goes
look man
look what the [ __ ] i'm working with hey
you just had your skin have been
slaughtered they would have been swollen
look what i'm wearing the whole sound
machine behind them that's hilarious
dude
they were all just sitting there like
you know
but then like i i used to go out a lot
because my brother my brother's type was
more masculine i talked about that in
in principal's office my special but he
was more masculine so
my brother dated some dudes like that
were you know he had there's one guy
this guy could throw hands man but you
know i wish more like i wish there'd be
some badass dudes in the nba or the nfl
that came out were
a gay you know what i mean like i i do
wish there was a
i mean a beast that came out to change
that stereotype of
what what what was behind your brother
first of all
i mean that [ __ ] hey man there's some
dudes that that are probably
yeah but yeah i used to see gay dudes at
the gym all the time and i mean
yoked stacked i would i where i would
never
never you know when i worked at the
cheesecake factory this brother came in
looked like [ __ ] wesley snipes
right and he was like and and he was
looking at me like yo man
and he had his dude was like this little
little gay asian dude
yeah but he's like hey man he's like yo
like he was kicking it to me like i was
like you know
he's like yo what's to do around here
man and he's staring at me i'm like i
don't know man
i'm trying to figure it out like what
like you know because this is hollywood
that could be his agent
you know what i mean that could be it
right he's like hey man give me your
phone number
and i'm like nah dude then i'm like
[ __ ] at least ask me for it at least
yeah right we don't [ __ ] demand it
but yeah man i was like you could tell
this dude's been through some [ __ ]
you know what i mean i'll tell you one
time it tripped me out i saw
it was two uh gang banger looking dudes
i mean hard looking dudes and then
we're sitting at the bar they're just
drinking whatever and they just start
making out and i
couldn't like throws you for a loop it
threw that threw me for a loop two men
kissing
not a problem but they were you know
tear drop tattoos and neckties and i was
like what the [ __ ] and it that blew a
stereotype
too you know what i mean like but i
gotta be honest with you man
most people i mean look people make
comments and you know but on a whole
i mean like every time i was out with my
brother there was one other time we were
at a bar
uh because my my stepsister worked at
hooters so we went over there to drink
and then my brother had his boyfriend
with him or
no it wouldn't it was just some dude he
was clipping
right and then and then i came with my
boy buff
who uh who he played at uh he played at
uh central florida his office attacked
he's a big kid
but bob is a tough kid but he's a very
level-headed guy like he's an offensive
lineman you know
they're yeah they are they're the
smarter guys and then uh
my brother's friend was but as we pulled
up to the bar i could feel something was
uncomfortable
and then um i could tell my brother was
like oh [ __ ]
right because when i showed up because i
i was a hot head when i was younger
and and and then i hear him laughing
behind me and i could tell and i said
what the [ __ ] going on
he said those guys behind us are being
[ __ ] but brett don't stir anything
and that and as they're talking to me i
put my arm over him
like this like we're dating oh yeah you
know what i mean
i put my head on his shoulder and he's
going brat stop brett stop
then then the dude started made another
comment and then i turned around and you
know
i had a couple words with him and then
you know my brother was pissed about it
but
that's probably the only time i maybe
maybe two or three times
but other than that you know it was more
fun dude
yeah he sounds like a really good big
brother actually
yeah dude he was [ __ ] that guy was
the best man let's take a quick break
and tell you about our next sponsor
hellofresh get
fresh pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door with
hellofresh america's number one
meal kit hellofresh lets you skip the
trips to the grocery store and makes
home cooking fun
easy and affordable hellofresh's recipes
are so delicious
they offer so many to choose from from
each week to help you break out of your
recipe rut there's something for
everyone including low calorie
vegetarian and family friendly aka picky
eater
recipes every week hellofresh offers
fresh high quality ingredients
for a super flavorful experience every
week over 90 percent of ingredients are
sourced directly from growers to ensure
the freshest recipes
are delivered to your door save time and
stress effortlessly
hellofresh offers contactless delivery
to your doorstep for easy home cooking
with the family
and hellofresh cuts out stressful meal
planning and grocery store trip so you
can enjoy cooking
and get dinner on the table in just
about 30 minutes or even 20 minutes
with some of their quick recipe options
go to hellofresh.com
honeydew80 and use the code honeydew80
to get a total of 80
off including free shipping on your
first box
additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com
for more details that's hellofresh.com
honeydew80. our next sponsor is
stamps.com now i go back a long way with
stamps.com when i was doing the crab
feast and first started merch i used
stamps.com all the time to scale
uh sealing them up sending them off it
was awesome
uh the only reason i stopped was because
thanks to you guys it got too much to
handle
so i loved it they've been great and
right now as we slowly adjust to a new
normal we still need to be smart about
how we do business all right so luckily
there's stamps.com to make things easier
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits of stamps.com in
recent months they've been able to keep
their businesses running
and avoid the crowds at the post office
all from their own computers with
stamps.com you can print postage on
demand
and avoid going to the post office and
you'll save money with discounted rates
you can't even get at the post office
stamps.com
also offers ups services shout out to
ups baltimore hub
primary one joe avenue with discounts up
to 62 percent
and no residential surcharges stamps.com
brings all the mailing and shipping
services you need
right to your computer in the comfort of
your home or
office whether you're a small business
sending invoices an online seller
shipping out products or just working
from home
and need to mail stuff stamps.com can
handle it all
with ease simply use your computer to
print official us postage
24 7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send once your mail is ready
you just leave it for your mail carrier
you schedule a pickup or you drop it in
a mailbox
it's that simple and like i said with
stamps.com you get great discounts too
five cents off every stamp
and up to 62 off usps and ups shipping
rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money
right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in honeydew
that's stamps.com
click on the microphone and enter
honeydew now
let's get back to the do when did you
clear the air on making fun of him for
being
overweight like that's what i'm trying
to tell him man and this is what
the world needs to know straight guys we
bond
through insulting each other we bond
through arguing with each other you know
what i mean we bond through all that
[ __ ]
like you know people are really close
men are close
when they're [ __ ] [ __ ] on each
other and that's what we do we [ __ ] on
each other in each other's face but when
your boy's not around is when you talk
them up
that's what this show is kicking you
when you're at your lowest
that's what this show is look my cousin
got married right this one still makes
me laugh
he was a cop he's on the force brand new
on the force
he's in a high speed chase like his
second day in the car with his partner
some lady cuts them off car rolls they
flip
he's got his leg shattered he's got to
get pins in it or whatever he's got this
walking boot he's about to get married
right
so he's he's at the altar or whatever he
gets emotional
and you know he cries a little bit uh
and then later that night at the
reception
there's this [ __ ] there's this i
in his defense there sh it should have
been marked it was just to step
down that you couldn't see you could not
[ __ ] see it
this [ __ ] hits it with that foot
he goes down he's on the ground
screaming he's got that tear whatever
that [ __ ] [ __ ] is
coming out of his eye and i'm just like
i just go over to him like hey
you quiet you cried twice at your
wedding day
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and we all were just
nobody helped him out but like you
helped us you're better you said i do
you help his ass up it was [ __ ] on you
immediately like even wisconsin timmy
cried twice at his wedding like
my stepfather they used to break his
balls but like he called him like
liberace he hey liberace
that's how italians insult people they
just call you famous people from your
group
hey richard simmons dance the [ __ ] over
here really quick and get me to [ __ ]
get me a glass out of the counter you
know
that's exactly what it is but no
i i was gonna say though uh but after
that man
you know i sent you in a [ __ ] after
that man cause we were very close i mean
yeah and that's the other thing too man
it's like uh i just love hearing that
you're
you know i i i it's important it's your
brother like you're accepting of it
you're not fighting because somebody's
not even a [ __ ] question but so many
people sit
on the cross here and and talk about how
they weren't accepted you know or what
you know their brothers weren't they
weren't there what i'm saying though man
like i said my
everybody i was raised with every crew i
mean look man
would i preferred him to be straight
[ __ ] yeah cause then he'd be alive
you know what i mean that's interesting
you know he would be
he would be a probably well he'd be 50
something years old so
you know what i mean i would have had my
mom would we probably i probably would
have been a grammar he could have been a
grandfather you know what i'm saying
but that's not who he was and you know
that's i never thought of it any other
way
that's just how i know him but then
again he may not have been a lie he
could have been a [ __ ]
he could have been worse than me you
know you don't know man but
anybody that that's your family and not
only that man that's the way
see look man people are born that way
and if that's the way they're born
that's the way god intended them to be
and god don't make [ __ ] mistakes you
know what i mean
but getting back to the other thing now
when when when
when the other thing i almost did one
night this was this was bad man
i was gonna break him out of the funeral
home that was all [ __ ] up man
what do you mean like like going and
[ __ ] the viewing you were gonna get
no no before when i knew he was on on
the slab before they [ __ ] uh
they did that i was hammered bro before
they embalmed them and everything yeah
what were you what
was it i don't know man what was the
question
or something i was [ __ ] out of my
car were you driving bro i wasn't man if
you didn't have a pickup truck i would
here's the worst part here's the [ __ ]
worst part
my buddy was driving and and i convi and
he's
he's like all right let's do it i don't
know if that's a good friend or a band i
don't know
you convinced him to do it i wanted to
get him out of there man it just
bothered me dude that that [ __ ]
bothered me
yeah but see again my family deals with
humor so getting back to when my father
passed i wanted to ask you so
i this is this is where comedy comes
from man
so the night he died my mom we found out
and my mom had to tell us she was
[ __ ] you know balling
she was like let's go see a movie all
right and
uh you know there was a comedy
can't wait to be here so we get to the
movies
give me four tickets for porkys no no
it's even worse
so we get to the theater and this is
typical my mom
right because she's my mom was very
naive we get to the theater
we're sitting in the theater it's me
scotty keith keith is too young and it
was a comedy
it was like the number one comedy and it
was called kiss me goodbye and it's with
jimmy khan and sally field
and the whole movie starts off with the
guy's dead like he's dying
and he comes back from the dead and it's
just about a guy who's dead
and my mom just starts crying she's like
and we you know we were you're not poor
i used the term poor
we were not that well-off but we were
never poor there was always food on the
table
you know but we we weren't well off so
we had all of our [ __ ] in the theater
you know your mom would come in
like my mother would bring like a two
liter bottle of soda you know you bring
your own candy
like people it would be quiet you just
hear like you know like
we had like all the shitty the wax candy
that you know remember those that were
coming to think they were like a dollar
you know so and we were just sitting
there and you know i just i just
remember like
just laughing and but we always joked
around man
so your brother is 14 at the time he
tells you your dad passes
he was there he came and got us and i
[ __ ] knew too man i see other things
so where was your dad
i know he was he was in new jersey he
was up in jersey yeah and you had no
real contact with him throughout that or
you would see him a little bit
we did we did you know we weren't um
you know we were kept away from him
because he had mental issues
okay he started uh he had schizophrenia
but he had uh
uh you know he he got in some trouble
and um what did he do like how did your
parents meet
they met uh my father my real father was
just you know regular guy
and then um they met on a blind date i
think
oh yeah but you know they're all from
the same area in jersey my mom was from
teaneck ridgefield park my dad was from
leone at the time
right near fort lee so they all knew
each other my mother originally was from
jersey city and
that area as well so so you know
1950 [ __ ] you know he wore leather
jacket drove a bike
you know he was he was a rough guy man
my father was a rough dude but he was
smart
man very smart man so what happened uh
he uh you know he had schizophrenia but
my
it's an interesting story about him
though man i mean he became very
successful
my dad became a lobbyist he lied he said
he went to college
then he became a lobbyist i mean you
know it's like i don't know how
i don't know if you don't know your
father or not but it's like it did for
60 he died when i was 16.
okay because i was gonna say if you
don't when you're younger it's almost
like a legend of somebody like you don't
really know him
but you always hear stories about it
yeah it's like the legend of your father
even though you know he [ __ ]
everything and
yeah dude i'm working on a story now um
about when the cops came to arrest him
he was hiding in the basement
but um so
but he you know he was mentally ill man
he was a sick dude and you know you
don't realize that you watch it in front
of you i talk about that in my last
special
um but you know he he had he would hear
voices and [ __ ] he would ramble
it was almost like charlie you know when
charlie sheen would get that crazy look
yeah you know and my dad smoked a [ __ ]
ton of weed and i think he did other he
had to have
um but that was later on which is why
i've never tried weed in my life i never
smoked anything
but he uh yeah he he he jumped off the
george washington bridge in uh what
enough
yeah and uh it's like it connects fort
lee to manhattan
yeah so it's right there so yeah that's
how he killed himself holy sh he jumped
off that [ __ ] bridge yeah he just
took a leap
what the [ __ ] he just walked out there
and said that [ __ ] with me too man
because
like the the the psychology behind it i
was watching this thing on the golden
gate bridge and
all those people that jumped yes they
are they said their last their first
thought was that liv that they what the
[ __ ] was i doing so you know that
bothered me
so what what happens then what happens
after
i mean you know he did it he did it with
the uh
with the intent that we were going to
get money the insurance money and then
again man
funds were cut off when we were 18 and
you know my mom still had
when my brother turned 18 she lost his
money right you know
yeah from social security and then so
you know things were tough man
things were tough but you know you just
you get you get through it
but yeah no i i uh he was a really smart
guy my father
really smart like everybody that said
that that knew him i mean
okay so he lied he said he went to
college and he worked his way up and
became
one of the top lobbyists in the state of
west virginia that's where we were
living at the time oh okay
where uh charleston okay i've been there
yeah and then
uh you know he went downhill after that
but nobody knew he was going crazy we i
knew
i kind of what what did you start seeing
[ __ ] staring at you all cockeyed and
[ __ ] you're like
[ __ ] this dude you just catch up yeah
i have a cousin who's a paranoid
schizophrenic and i've talked about it
here on
rogan and everything and it's it's
different man
it's you do see it like there are times
when i knew he was on his meds and he
started telling
family secrets and everybody like don't
listen to him like no no no
i see it i can see it he's he's clear
he's
right there i know he's with it right
now and then there are other times where
it's that that just lost look that you
could you're just like man there's
nothing there's no one in there right
now
and i would see that from time to time
and i'm like ah so i know that look
you're talking about
but yeah it um you know you you feel bad
for him but you don't realize that as a
kid i just remember being frustrated
that i couldn't see him
how was he when he passed uh 38. oh he's
young
yeah oh that's young dude yeah he's mad
young
and but like i remember being frustrated
that i can't go see him and then you get
resentful
but you know i don't know yeah i'm like
why can't i see dad
and then my mom's like just you know you
get mad at her like you think she's
keeping him from you but yeah i don't
know the guy's [ __ ] nuts
you sound like you get a great mom my
mom's the best and i
i say carol's the best what's up carol
um
parenting is a long-term game man it's
you're you're resenting your mom at that
time and now you look back that she's
protecting you
it's not like i hate her it's like i
resent her like she doesn't play ice
cream right yeah you know what i mean
but it doesn't pay dividends until you
know hopefully you've done the right job
with your kid
i'll tell you right now if it wasn't for
my grandparents
oh done what do you mean my nanny and
poppy man they they took us in they
raised us they did well my mom would
have to work
so we would stay with them and what were
they like
oh god bro mike graham this is your
mom's parents my mom's been yes
because you know that's what happened
you spent you go with the minor all the
time i had my grandmother raised you're
sleeping
you know we we would sleep wherever we
had room in that place
but my grandmother man they they always
made sure like i remember my grandfather
very proud sicilian man you know he's
like it's easter
and those kids have to wear easter suits
you know and he would always get us to
eat
we just have to dress up in easter suits
and easter sunday mass
there was like that's where i was
instilled with that pride and my
grandmother was just such a wise woman
loving i mean church went to church
during the week yeah right
why are you on a wednesday i'm just
about to say grandma why are you going
wednesday night
what's going on it's like some saint day
and
she don't even know every night you pray
for everybody you pray for
all the people in the world we'll do the
rosary every night yeah the novena
when something was going on but you know
it's just very look dude
at the end of the day man i'll i'll take
i'll take my childhood over anything
isn't that i love hearing that me too
i would if i had to go back and do all
that [ __ ] again
i would absolutely do it again uh the
loss
all of it it was worth it those people
were worth it i look now and think man
that was
my 16 years with my father was worth
every second of that
um all right so now i want to ask you
because this is your first time here
um especially after all the stuff we've
talked about and all the stuff
i will say really quick though go ahead
that all
like right now when i was an adult
it helped me through everything like oh
that that whole childhood of
of you know you just all your trials and
tribulations eventually
make sense my all of my [ __ ] made sense
the minute i stepped on stage
the lowest lowest point after my brother
died i mean i was a grown man i had zero
on my account i
i stopped working i got fired i had to
be home i had to be with my mom
and i remember i went out to l.a already
i was already doing comedy dude like i
was at the store everything
you know and i was still i got fired
from the cheesecake factory
and i was standing there and you know
you you go to your friends your boys so
they know i needed cash so like look man
you know
you can go one or two ways so i says you
know look man i just work security at
the club
for you know one of my buddies on the
club so i'm bouncing at the club
and people are coming up to me going you
know
i thought you were doing comedy and you
know what's funny
and it never bothered me because i
observe
the look of satisfaction in some
people's faces when when they think
you're failing
and that's the other thing man and yeah
i
recently just went through a divorce and
you know
you people don't realize what we put
into this
so i've been doing it 23 years and in
that 23 years
from from the night i got on stage after
my brother passed to
i mean dude i was delivering pizzas at
[ __ ] 31 man i'm a grown man
you know you know what i mean i
literally it's the i tell like there's a
quick story
first time i was on national tv doing
comedy i had to deliver pizzas
so i we you know you shoot during the
day i couldn't get off of work it was
when the
uh the lakers were winning everything oh
man nothing
nothing kills comedy shows so i'm
delivering pizzas and i had this 97 ford
escort that if you made lefts it would
[ __ ] stall out
so like by the way i'm in my 30s i'm not
a kid
so i had to go here i have to make a
right and then a right and then another
right overshoot that [ __ ] to
make a right
so i i i'm waiting my boss is like brett
well you know we're slammed and i'm like
all right fine whatever
uh my brother keith was gonna record it
anyways with the vcr i'll watch it later
dude i get to the dude's house i open
the [ __ ] door and i'm on [ __ ] tv
i swear to god i'm standing there with a
[ __ ] large pie
and the dude's staring at me the look
the look on his face was like oh my god
how cool
this is the most depressing [ __ ]
thing i've ever seen in my life also
you know i made a joke i'm like i guess
i'm fast right
so i said you mind and we sat there and
i and i watched
that's how you watched this yeah i
watched like i watched like the last
three minutes
dude didn't laugh once i was embarrassed
i got the [ __ ] out dude i made like 18
rights and got the [ __ ] out of them
dude another time i'm i'm on the plane
and my half hour on comedy central was
on
and i'm sitting uh you know and you know
sometimes when you i don't like to talk
to the people
because if they ask you what you do i'm
like i'm a teacher i don't say comedian
either i do not
know well how come i don't know who you
are yeah why are you in coach what have
you been on
yeah why are you doing do you write your
own material why are you sitting next to
me
you know i did stand up once i'm like
here we go do you know when they list
whoever the [ __ ]
your friends are you're like yeah i know
them they're in first class right now
so i'm opening for him he's like yeah
he's right up there
so but now the dude's watching my
special so i'm i'm like this
and i'm trying to see and he has he put
two and two together yeah no because i'm
like oh [ __ ]
then he just goes
i'll just [ __ ] chase that
[ __ ]
[Music]
i'm like [ __ ] hey man
no but the [ __ ] that we go through and
when you
finally get your break you know what i
mean
and you're finally on something how
awful is that that somebody pulls up a
tweet
from 20 years ago or whatever the [ __ ]
and they just take it all away
just like that you know
that's why you when you build that
foundation
like you know yeah because there's an
evolution i'm not the same dude at 20
that i was
no no i mean look and now i'm pushing
i'm middle-aged dude i'm 40 uh you know
i'm in my
late 40s i'm 47. if i was the same
person i was at 18
what a piece of [ __ ] i mean people
here's the other thing man
and i'm with you on this you have to
make mistakes
a lot of people need to to make a
mistake to understand their ignorance or
understand that something's wrong and
then
the apology is the change in behavior
moving forward you don't always have to
be like i'm sorry
like hey here's the i'm sorry is you
called out the behavior you're right i
corrected it
and it's never happening again that's
how you move forward you don't
everything is please allow people to be
imperfect plea
how else do you learn and and but that
when you go through life
when you go through some [ __ ] early on
it helps you later on and
you know like i was you know comedy has
cost me a lot
it's cost you know i was it's cost me
everything
yeah even my wife and it had nothing to
do with selfish but i meant it had
nothing to do with
anything other than you're on the road
30 weeks and and you know
drift apart things happen you know
i mean you know people disconnect and
you know you care about each other but
you just give up a lot for it and uh
and i wouldn't change one [ __ ] thing
dude
that's my high point is stand up all
right
so now all of it advice to your 16 year
old self
relax you're gonna get [ __ ]
you're gonna get a lot of [ __ ] just
chill don't [ __ ] chase it
um yeah i would i would say
i would honestly say um
pay attention in films man for football
but
i dude i was just such a reactatory
player on the field that if i would have
really studied films
i would have [ __ ] think i could have
went a little further yeah um
i don't know man that would just i don't
know what i'd tell them i just say buck
buckle in man it's a [ __ ] dude like i
said man
i i've been reading uh there's a
philosophy called stoicism
and it's something that i it didn't
you know some things change the way you
think and then something's confirmed the
way you think
i've always viewed the the the failures
and
and and the um you know the the sad
points in your life
as you're supposed to embrace them
you're supposed to love them
and you know a lot of my friends i was
always surrounded by drugs man
and you know i'm not gonna lie i've had
seven of my closest friends have been in
prison for a while
and two are left damn and yeah i still
uh
it's so funny too man like when you get
around normal people
you know what i mean and and you know
like there's people i know that don't
know anybody that's ever been to jail
you know what i mean and but when you're
and i talk about that in the principal's
office when you grow up in dysfunction
you just
you think everybody does until you meet
normal people you know you're like you
know you know
really this is obscure absurd to you
but there's a scene in braveheart where
he
spits the morphine out and people used
to say you know even at my lowest times
i stayed away from all that [ __ ]
one i knew i was afraid i'd be addicted
to it because i had that crazy gene
in my family uh two the smell of
marijuana
because my dad smoked it all the [ __ ]
time um
i never wanted to try it i i don't think
it's wrong at all
like now i actually like to smell but
back then it just turned me off to it
but when he spits that morphine out and
he's like i want to have my wits about
me
people that that that start to
self-medicate to get away from the pain
take that [ __ ] in take it all in
absorb it
make it work for you enjoy it love it
respect it with the same respect
that you do the good that's right you
know what i mean it's all you signed up
for this show you need it
you need those you need you signed up
for it before you came down from heaven
and you're up there and they said hey
listen kid
this is what's going to happen you want
in and you're like [ __ ] and buckle me in
let's go that's what i believe
i know that's what you know i mean so
like you know i'm in let's do it i'm in
it to win it man and if if
this has happened this is what happens
because at the end of the day everybody
has the same fate bro
we're all gone we're all [ __ ] gonna
die and we are all gonna die what i mean
so and then i just you know you just do
what you love man
everybody always say too is it the
destination or the journey
uh it's the people that you're on the
journey with man i agree with that
our crew is [ __ ] yeah i've met some
wonderful [ __ ] people hell yeah
for real um well thank you dude thank
you for opening up thank you for being
honest
i'll go to brettcomedy.com bretwith1t
comedy.com if you want to watch
principal's office i actually
uh when i self-distributed it i just set
it up where people can watch it for free
if you want to leave an email leave an
email
if you want to buy it you can buy it for
five bucks cobra kai again
september 28th september oh no wait i'm
sorry august 20th august 20th on netflix
on netflix great anything else uh no
that's about it man and keep keep uh you
know keep supporting live comedy
you know all right man thank you for
doing this for real you got it brother
uh ryan sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all next
[Applause]
[Music]
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you